le l'humanité ça ça nous appartient à
tous et une histoire où il n'y aurait
que des noirs peut-être tout aussi
porteuse d'humanité qu'une histoire où
il y aurait que des blancs
[Musique]
c'est un conte africain bien sûr mais
c'est une histoire universelle et le
fait qu'un cinéaste européens fassent
kirikou mais qui rendent hommage à la
culture du continent noir
pour moi c'est comme une c'est comme un
premier pas pour dire ok c'est un relais
que je vous tends joutes en maintenant à
vous raconter vos histoires parce que
vos histoires sont belles le l'humanité
ça nous appartient à tous et est une
histoire où il n'y aurait que des noirs
peut-être tout aussi porteuse d'humanité
qu'une histoire aurait que des blancs et
chacun peut et doit raconter son
histoire et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui concerne le continent africain
on a très peu finalement de deux
cinéastes africains qui se raconte et
qui raconte véritablement leur histoire
il est temps qu'on entende plus c'est
beaucoup les cinéastes du continent
africain où on est reparti sur un moment
particulier pour l'afrique avec toutes
les crises migratoires et tout ce qu'on
nous puisqu'on peut les moyens quelque
chose que je dis assez souvent c'est que
il ya eu on a construit un regard et
tout un discours une idéologie au mieux
racialisée au pire raciste en fait sur
l'autre et sur le noir et d'une certaine
manière ce si on a pu construire un
regard on peut déconstruire le regard et
pour moi ce genre de film montre
finalement une vision positive du
continent africain et des africains et
des noirs ça participe à la
déconstruction du regard pour qu'on se
rende compte que l'humanité n'est pas
l'apanage de ceux qui ont la peau claire
c'est pas tant pour moi que c'est
important c'est important j'ai envie de
dire pour les petits enfants blancs qui
ont vu ce film
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'en
fait c'est important que le petit enfant
blanc qui voit ce film
en voyant ça il se pose pas de questions
il se dit ben c'est un enfant etc et il
va grandir avec ça en lui
ce qui fait que quand il va voir l'autre
qui ne lui ressemble pas extérieurement
il va pas voir l'autre il va avoir une
variation de lui-même
d'une certaine manière et ça c'est
important